- All right, I always love to close out
with something fun and inspiring.
This is "#What I'm Liking."
(upbeat music)
Earlier this year we had P!nk here
for a whole hour, because why not?
I love her.
We also featured an artist
that she worked with named Tim Wakefield.
He creates one of a kind
pieces depicted in sound waves,
and he auctions them off
for worthy charities.
To date, his organization
Sound Waves Art Foundation
has raised nearly $7
million, which is incredible.
When they were here,
he debuted a new piece,
the image of my song
"Broken and Beautiful,"
which is actually written by P!nk.
(audience applauding)
P!nk and I both signed the piece,
and I'm so excited to say
it was bought for $50,000
at auction with the proceeds
going to No Kid Hungry.
We have Tim on the line
right now to tell us more.
What's up Tim?
Nice to see you again.
- Hi Kelly.
Hi Kelly, happy birthday.
- Thank you, thank you so much.
So you met the woman who
bought the piece, right?
- Oh, incredible.
So she, yeah, as you
said, she bid $50,000,
so we thought the least we could do
is fly her down from Atlanta.
So we brought her to, there she is,
we brought her to Lockhart, Texas.
And we took her to barbecue,
and then we showed we
unveiled her artwork for her
and her partner.
And to say it was emotional
would be an understatement.
One of the best moments of my career.
There's a lot of
expletives and swear words
that I couldn't possibly
repeat on your show,
but it was fantastic.
And, thanks to you and thanks to her,
we've now raised over $60,000
in total for No Kid Hungry.
- Wow.
- So that's amazing.
- That's so incredible.
And, I hear that you're actually embarking
on a new project right now, right?
- Yeah, we are.
I mean, we couldn't do what we do
without the help of musicians.
So, I think, as you say,
"It's time to pay it forward."
So, a lot of musicians,
I come from Austin, Texas
where we've got about 12,000
people in the industry.
Many of them living on, you know,
beneath the poverty line
in the music industry.
So we've got 24 local musicians
launching a collection
of artwork in May for Mental Health Month.
And we are working with a
local charity called SIMS,
and we're gonna provide
mental health services
for musicians and people
in the music industry.
And beyond that, we're gonna be working
with Sweet Relief Musicians
Fund who do a similar thing
on a national basis.
And the good news is,
we're gonna now take this
to other music tens, starting
with Nashville in 2024.
So, very exciting stuff.
- Oh, that's incredible!
Congratulations, man,
and thank you so much
for all you're doing.
I'm liking your post
right now, right, Tim?
(audience cheering)
- [Tim] Oh, thank you so much.
And we couldn't have done
it without your help,
so thank you so much.
- Well, yeah, well that's not all,
our season long partner,
Pilot Pen, makers of FriXion,
the Go-To Erasable Pen of
"The Kelly Clarkson Show"
love how you're using art and music
to support all sorts of people in need.
So in honor,
they are giving Sweet Relief
Musicians Fund $1,000.
How's that sound?
(audience cheering)
- Wow.
- [Kelly] Thank you, Tim!
And thank you to all our guests this hour
who celebrated my birthday
with me, Jimmy Allen,
the BoykinZ, Mikaela, Jude and Isaiah.
I hope you're all having a great day.
And thank you once again to
everybody who did a video,
that was very sweet.
Jake Gyllenhaal, you're hilarious.
If it's not a great day, y'all, change it.